before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
so much for that flat team structure
thank you
[Music]
take two Doctor Who reviews continue and
this time it is the haunting of villa
diadati now this one uh was actually
very well received when it first came
out now part of that had to do I think
with a certain amount of anticipation of
what was going to come later because we
have the initial payoff of the lone
Cybermen in ashad who is a really great
character I'll talk about him a little
bit more later but a bit like with
fugitive of the jidoon
some of at least initial excitement for
it was probably built around what is
this building to
um the answer being
not a whole lot so it does suffer from
that in the same way that fugitive of
the Dune did but beyond that this is
still a very well liked episode uh in
certain circles uh certain uh chiminal
critical circles it's often cited as the
only good one of his era or at the very
least the best one and
I am now going to be super contrarian
cause
I kinda hate it
now before you before you write your
comment telling me how wrong I am I
should explain
it's not bad actually certain aspects of
it are great the atmosphere is fantastic
the guest cast is pretty solid uh
there's just a good overall creeping
Vibe a shot is a fascinating character
he's got a terrific design there's a lot
to like about this
it's not that there's nothing good or
even that there's a ton of stuff that's
bad
this a lot of it is going to be fairly
personalized to me because the things
that I don't like about this
I really really
hate
and in some ways they
exemplify some of the worst habits of
not just this era of Doctor Who but of
Doctor Who in general because I love
this show but sometimes it does stuff
that I'm like I really wish you wouldn't
do that and
um this is this is in some way is if
you've been following this this uh
particular series of take two reviews
um is some things coming home to roost
because I had been alluding to some
things like the great men of history
approach to going over historical
periods
um and you know the casualness and the
cruelty towards secondary characters uh
that in earlier reviews I alluded to
yeah we're gonna come back to that later
on this is where that's gonna come back
up again
and I'm not saying anyone else has to
dislike this episode
but the things that it does
for me that rubbed me the wrong way
really
really rub me the wrong way
and this is not the idiot's Lantern
levels these are this isn't a case of it
being a uh core morality message that is
so
intrinsically harmful that it makes me
want to actively erase it from Canon I
don't feel that about this but it does
hit some really bad nerves with me
we will get to that in a little bit
though because I know once I start on
that stuff I will get ranty about it so
let's acknowledge what else there is and
what is good as I said the atmosphere is
absolutely top-notch the I'm going in
circles around the uh around inside the
manor and just the Simplicity of how
that is shot it's done very very simply
but it's very effectively done I
actually quite like the fact that like
the ghost Maiden the little girl that
Graham is seeing never get explained I
think that should happen more often in
Doctor Who to be honest
um that just sometimes there's stuff
that no uh we don't uh we don't know
what that was
good you should know everything that
goes on in the universe universe is too
big for anyone to know everything
especially the doctor so I like that I'm
good with that
I liked the uh the way that the
historical figures were portrayed they
were portrayed as very human which is
nice it
um in terms of the characterization of
them it was not overly exalting of these
people it was acknowledging them as
human beings with flaws uh or in the
case of someone like Byron just kind of
a bit of a dick which yeah sure that
works then there's Fletcher the valet I
love like Fletcher is the best he just
has these little moments these little
eye rolls these little this droll
responses like he knows how moronic
these wealthy romantic artistic types
are and but it's his job to put up with
them so he does but I love Fletcher he
is he is amazed every second he's on
screen and oftentimes he doesn't even
have lies but just the Expressions on
his face I love him there's a shot who I
mentioned earlier first of all the ways
in which he's introduced into the story
you know the early hints just out over
the lake great visuals on that I like
how you know obviously he's a cyber man
that's a Cyberman but like it's rusted
out half the thing is missing we can see
his face underneath he freely expresses
that he's feeling emotions
and yet he still still working for the
Cybermen he's still working with them
and then we find out towards the end
voluntarily so far as we can tell he is
fascinating and terrifying to think
about the kind of person
who would not even be fully converted
but would still be happy to work with
and for the Cybermen
he's great and he and that look is
fantastic he is an excellent villain an
excellent threat he is intimidating he
is familiar while also being alien and
that's not an easy thing to do
especially in the long-running show like
this
this is what something like evolution of
the dialects tried to do and failed at
this is succeeding at it like that's
definitely a cyber man
but there's something else going on and
it's intriguing and it's off-putting and
it's great
and so with all these strengths going on
with this thing
why do I hate it
well uh it starts to come apart
in the back half
firstly
we have the death of Fletcher
I was really irritated to find out that
he died because he just got lifted up by
the neck and then tossed just on the
floor that looks survivable
but we find out he's dead and we get
this tiny little acknowledgment from
Byron
and then we move on there's also a maid
who dies maid is not nearly as memorable
or wonderful a character as Fletcher but
she dies I don't think she even gets
named now in and of itself these things
are well
not good but there that's no more
egregious than any other episode of
Doctor especially the Chipmunk or Doctor
Who I have noted that there's been a
certain callousness uh to the deaths of
secondary and Side characters
um if the episode is not explicitly
about them if they zoom in and really
focus like okay you know maybe something
like uh Demons of the Punjab we're
really going to focus and zoom in on
these characters and appreciate the
tragedy of their death but if an episode
is not doing that people who are
established to have outside lives to
have families grandkids boyfriends Etc
are killed off very casually with very
little acknowledgment from either the
episode of the characters and so that
happens again here but again that's a
recurring issue why does it bother me
more here
because of the context of what happens
later when they finally find Percy
Shelley
who has the siberium inside of himself
and is trying to hold off the lone
Cyberman and Ryan asked the question and
I'm not saying it's what the character
should have done but he asks what is
under the circumstances a valid question
they're fighting to save Shelley and the
doctor is considering giving the
siberium to the lone cyber I mean giving
the Cybermen what he wants which is what
she was explicitly told to not do and
Ryan brings up the fact sure there's
only one laugh against all those of us
now the doctor pushes back on that which
she should
the doctor should always push back on
that idea because we don't willfully
sacrifice someone we don't throw a life
away like that we don't do that kind of
cold calculated math that treats people
as numbers only and never acknowledges
them as people so the doctor was right
to push back on that
the problem
is that she pushes back by Framing it
along the lines of Percy Shelley's
importance
thoughts his words Inspire and influence
thousands for centuries if he dies now
who knows what damage that will have on
future history
she brings up all the people that his
Works will inspire
she brings up this idea that words
matter
in an episode where two people already
died and she did not blink the only
person who got any acknowledgment was
Fletcher and that was from Byron the
doctor just moved on no acknowledgment
of the two people already dead but him
he's important hey it's me from the
editing phase I want to clarify
something here yes the doctor also talks
about how this will impact future
history how this will make the world
that gave her Ryan and Yaz and Graham
not the same world they won't be the
same people they may not exist so she
does move it beyond the scope of him but
she's still pivoting on him and saying
that basically the world changes on
Percy Shelley and I'm sure some people
will argue well because she's the doctor
she has a full view of the scope of
history and she knows that his death
would impact that in a way that Fletcher
or the mains wouldn't that's a
logistical explanation that wouldn't fix
my problems with the overall messaging
because no matter how you justify it
narratively it still feeds the overall
concept that the important people
recorded by history matter more than
those who weren't and I feel like it's
worth pointing out the last time the
doctor started to do these calculations
of who mattered and ignoring the rest of
them it was painted as a really bad
thing who decides they're so unimportant
you you and I don't even like Waters of
Mars all that much but at least it
understood that when the doctor starts
acknowledging some lives is more
important than ignoring others that's
bad not just in terms of possible damage
but it's bad for the doctor as a person
I said nothing you can't do
not anymore anyways back to my original
points
so here we have the great man of History
nonsense that only the people Remember
by the history books count and we
literally have the doctor ignoring the
deaths that have already happened
and defending the saving of this man's
life which again she should be doing but
she's doing it on the basis of he's too
important to die
that is wrong
that is not who the doctor should ever
be every life is supposed to matter can
the doctor save every life no does the
doctor in various incarnations at
various times has the doctor had to make
absolutely horrible decisions yes
but if the doctor is going to push back
on this idea that we let Shelley die it
should not be on the basis of his words
mattered it should be because he is a
human being whose life has just as much
value as anyone else's including the two
people who already died
and then there's just the use of the
term words matter look
this this is
as someone who is themself a writer
I hate
the tendency
of writers to exalt the importance of
poets writers and storytellers
words Matter wrote the author whose
business is words
and I'm not saying words don't matter
they do but I don't want to hear it
written on the page and then delivered
by proxies for the writer
the only but the only
writer that I can think of who has
managed to pull that off and not piss me
off
was Neil Gaiman with Sandman but that
was because he exalted the importance of
the stories and almost never the authors
of them and in fact some of the few
times that that story focused on
individual authors they were awful
people so the importance there was the
stories not the people who wrote them
down another quick point of clarity this
is not me saying you should separate the
artist from the art I've said before why
I think that's a bad idea this is me
saying that I appreciate stories about
stories but not stories about how
amazing people are for telling them hear
the emphasis she may say words matter
but she's saying it while pointing at we
can't let this man die we can't let this
writer die writers are too important
wrote the writer
so that's also a little bit of a nerve
with me and then there's the then
there's another thing
I hate
that this episode implies even slightly
that Mary Shelley was inspired to write
Frankenstein because of the events of
this now to be fair it's not as
straightforward as that it is a little
bit muddier because
um the doctor does point out fairly
early on like things are wrong Percy
Shelley should be here now so there's an
implication that at a point previous
history did play out the way we all know
it where they all gathered together and
challenged each other to come up with
frightening stories that that did happen
but it's not happening now because of
the lone cyber man the presence of the
doctor Etc so in some version of events
Mary Shelley did write Frankenstein
completely on her own ideas
however this still puts forward this
whole thing of she uh you know is they
keep cutting to her whenever they talk
about how the Cyber man works and
effectively dead body brought together
by electricity she's looking at a shot
and talking about how you know are you
more than one person are you pulled
together from multiple sources This
Modern Prometheus which was the subtitle
to Frankenstein
how dare you
exalt the importance of Percy Shelley
while implying that Mary Shelley's ideas
weren't her own ideas but were
influenced by these events that she
didn't think of this stuff that it
wasn't her own mind and her own
creativity
this isn't quite this isn't quite on the
level of like the original Back to the
Future implying that rock and roll the
original rock and roll sound was not in
fact invented by black people as it
actually was
but it's in the same ballpark it's
pulling the same nonsense
the stuff that this episode does
at the very end
ignoring the deaths that have already
happened zooming in on one of the great
historical figures of history and going
off on how important he is and look
Jody Whitaker delivers all this really
well that entire speech that entire
speech starting from words matter all
the way through because sometimes his
team structure isn't flat
is mountainous with me at The Summit in
the stratosphere alone she delivers it
really well
I just hate what it is she's delivering
but she sells it she sells it
excellently
if I actually liked the speech in and of
itself worth a damn I would have
included it in my top 10 speeches in
Doctor Who because she sells it so well
but I hate it
I hate it because at this point in my
life I am so sick
of the Great Men view of History I'm
sick of how Doctor Who as a franchise
falls into that as a general rule
whenever it does historical episodes I
don't like this era's callousness
towards the death of other people and
it's made worse here because it's an
episode where she's gonna go off on the
importance of one man while ignoring all
the deaths that have already happened I
hate the exaltation of writers you know
in a work that originally started in the
written form as a script written by
writers and I the sort of even the
implication even the Vegas hint of
removing the agency of Mary Shelley's
own creative genius in creating
Frankenstein is offensive intellectually
offensive to me
I hate this episode
if none of these things bother you there
is a lot to love here
I've talked about it already there's a
lot that's really really good
but the stuff that it does towards the
end
hits the worst kind of nerve for me on
multiple points it's not even just one
thing it's like three or four things
that all happen at the very end and
they're all nerves for me that this
thing just hits in the worst way
so I guess
um
in addition to being the one person who
says that can you hear me is the best
episode I'm now also the one person that
says uh hunting a villa dear daddy is
bad actually
I don't actually think I don't think
it's bad I do think it falls apart
very roughly
it doesn't stick The Landing
how much disagreement am I gonna get on
this you know what's going to be an
interesting one when I eventually get to
it I don't know if I'm going to jump at
the flux right off the bat once I finish
series 12 but if I even if I do uh I'm
gonna be really curious to see what
people's current feelings on Village of
the Angels was because I remember being
the outlier on that too everyone else
was like it's amazing I was like it
starts out okay but it falls apart real
bad and that's where I'm at right now
with this one and I don't know if people
still think it's amazing the general
impression I get is that they do
so go ahead and sign off in the comments
about how wrong I am or if I didn't
completely alienate you consider
supporting me on patreon it's what makes
this entire series and indeed this
Channel and my livelihood and ability to
buy food for my kid even possible but
even if uh you can't support me there
like share subscribe help as well but
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are important
even if you are not remembered by
history
you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
well it's patreon supporter Shout Out
Time folks so thank you to Robin Moore
Zubin lupula to rock the thing that goes
doink in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters imodelki Theo
the Boyd toy lowly Becky spark for Nabi
lacks the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
General contact unit Problem Child angry
Casper Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose thanks so
much for your help you can get your name
right out too check out the rewards in
the patreon
so what they should do should they check
[Music]